[Applause]
ceos know that hiring the right people
can make a company
elon musk personally interviews
candidates himself to this day
for certain high profile positions
spacex is hiring big
time musk tweeted his company needs
engineers technicians builders and
essential support personnel in and
around southern texas
home to its production facility and
launch site for a starship
he expects to bring in several thousand
more people over the next year or two
but if you want one of the key jobs
you'll have to pass muster
so what does musk look for in job
candidates according to a biography by
ashley vance he's been known to ask
people riddles during job interviews
like this imagine if you're standing on
the surface of the earth
you walk one mile south one mile west
and one mile north
you end up exactly where you started
where are you
one answer is the north pole if you
start there and go a mile south then a
mile west and then a mile north
you'll make a triangular path and end up
back at the north pole
but there's actually more than one
answer musk has been known to follow up
with
where else could you be the answer is
somewhere close to the south pole
imagine a circle with a one mile
circumference if you started a mile
north of the circle
and traveled a mile south then a mile
west all the way around the circle
then a mile north you'd be back at your
starting point
musk is said to care less about whether
the person gets the right answer
and more about how they try to solve the
problem the approach is key as he
explained in this interview with the
leading german automobile magazine
when i interviewed somebody i really
just asked them to tell me the story of
their career what are some of the
tougher problems that they dealt with
how they dealt with those
and how they made decisions at key
transition points
and usually that's enough for me to get
a very good gut feel
about someone and in order to spot
someone who is less than honest he says
he pays attention to whether they can
describe
their solution in detail detectives use
the same strategy during interrogations
honesty helped sunder bachai land a job
at google when interviewers asked what
he thought of gmail the very same day it
launched
he said he couldn't answer the question
because he hadn't been able to use the
product
that impressed the interviewers enough
to move him to the next rounds
just a decade later he became ceo before
even getting a shot at ac an interview
simply getting an interview could be
tough musk has questioned whether one of
the greatest inventors of all time
nikola tesla would have even gotten to
the interview stage at the company that
now bears his name
the tesla ceo has even said this is
actually one of my big worries
if nikola tesla was alive today could he
get an interview
and if not we're doing something wrong
and i'm not totally sure he would get an
interview in order to minimize the
chance that brilliant people aren't
overlooked
he says his companies don't always focus
on the school candidates attended or
even if they graduated from university
on tesla's career page the requirement
to be a software engineer for its
artificial intelligence team
is either a bachelor of science in an
applicable field or
proof of exceptional skills something
that musk has repeated over and over
again
looking just for evidence of exceptional
ability
it's unclear how many people who lack a
degree have actually been hired at tesla
but agree or not almost pass a hardcore
coding test
those closest to musk believe he has a
knack for hiring talent
when he started recruiting for spacex in
the early 2000s
musk ended up meeting an engineer named
tom mueller through an amateur rocket
club in california
he spoke with mueller for hours and knew
he had struck gold
mueller has been called the modern day
godfather of rocket science he led the
design of spacex's merlin engines that
power the falcon line of rockets before
he retired last year
elon was very good at recognizing talent
and hired people that
recognized talent i feel like my group
propulsion was really strong just
hired really smart people trained them
right and
it's hard to be a small group of really
smart people but that doesn't mean musk
is easy to have as a boss
headlines have detailed complaints by
former employees
over difficult working conditions musk
is also said to expect a level of
excellence from staff
take it from dali singh the former head
of talent acquisition
at spacex when someone on the question
and answer site cora asked what is it
like to work with or for
elon musk she responded working with him
isn't a comfortable experience
he is never satisfied with himself so he
is never really satisfied with anyone
around him
he pushes himself harder and harder and
he pushes others around him the exact
same way
the challenge is that he is a machine
and the rest of us aren't
so if you work for elon you have to
accept the discomfort but in that
discomfort is the kind of growth you
can't get anywhere else
and worth every ounce of blood and sweat
musk has also given his staff advice on
how they can be more productive
he once reportedly sent an email to
tesla staff suggesting they try to avoid
holding too many meetings
even saying people should feel free to
walk out of a meeting if they're not
adding any value
whether you're employed at tesla or any
company it's about working as
efficiently as possible
as someone who uses the internet for
everything when i create these videos i
often have to access various sites for
research
thankfully dashlane saves me a lot of
time by autofilling my login information
dashlane gives you everything you need
to easily manage your passwords and keep
them secure
with dashlane logging into a website is
as easy as clicking login and letting
autofill do the rest
autofill also works with credit cards
and addresses to make your online
shopping
seamless and easy dashlane also works on
multiple devices
so if you need to log into an account on
your phone tablet or desktop
you'll always have access to your
passwords and account information
on top of all of that dashlane also has
a vpn that stops your internet service
provider from tracking your web activity
and allows you to watch shows and movies
that are unavailable in your country on
websites like netflix
if you find this as helpful as i do you
can try dashlane for free on your first
device
at dashlane.com newsthink and if you
decide to upgrade to premium you can use
my code
newsthink for 50 off the link is in my
description
for news think i'm cindy palm